hi everyone i'm mike curran i'm here to
talk to you about some work our lab's
been doing um around hypoxia and how it
creates a major barrier to the success
of uh well spontaneous t-cell immunity
as well as immunotherapy particularly in
what we refer to as immune cold tumors
those that
lack prior immune infiltration don't
respond well to immunotherapy things
like pancreatic cancer prostate cancer
glioblastoma um i'd like to thank the
lab roots team for inviting me uh to
give this presentation as part of the
immuno oncology
uh
virtual uh
conference here
so without further ado uh
i have some disclosures let's consider
them now disclosed
and let's sort of set the stage with
immunotherapy so you know what's evolved
over the last decade is immunotherapy
has become a real pillar of oncology how
we treat cancer patients and you know
largely this is some work that i did a
long time ago
um with this gentleman here jim allison
winner of the nobel prize for sort of
being a pioneer of of this field of
checkpoint blockade and immunotherapy
but really showing this is why
immunotherapy has been so compelling
right we can block individual immune
checkpoints
markers on uh
on
t cells that are engaged by tumors to
shut off uh your adaptive immune
response when it comes knocking tries to
eliminate the cancer
when they're blocked now your t cells
are not shut off and tumors are cured uh
even in very uh
difficult to treat in transgen tumor
models this is a mouse model of melanoma
that's extraordinarily difficult to
treat um
combinations of these so blocking these
two primary immune checkpoints or again
switches uh that are engaged on t cells
to turn off uh
their function and shield tumors uh
ctla4 and pd1 together we showed you
know this could cure a very high
percentage of animals and really
shutting down this whole pathway so
blocking the interaction of these pd
ligands with pd-1
as well as this b71 pdl1 uh
co-inhibitory interaction described by
arlene sharp and gordon freeman allow to
secure the majority of animals and you
know this was very successful in a mouse
melanoma model uh often we see things
successful in mice that don't turn out
to be quite so successful in patients
unfortunately this was so this was
actually um you know we were very happy
to see that when you went into melanoma
which we now consider you know a great
success for immunotherapy but a 2-year
survival of about 80
you know 60 objective response rate and
really you know maybe 10 to 20 of these
patients are durably cured of detectable
disease
uh just to put it in perspective because
you know in in the 2020s world we think
of melanoma as you know an easy cancer
to treat with immunotherapy
in 2010 you know when this work started
the two-year survival rate for melanoma
was only 18
so this has really been transformational
in that setting led to uh fda approval
of this as the first uh immune
combination for checkpoint antibodies
and and one that's now been extended to
many indications
however despite all that success in in
more immunogenic tumors like melanoma
and lung cancer what we call hot cancer
is hot because they're immune
infiltrated at baseline they have a lot
of mutations that are immune visible
unfortunately those cancers are a
minority of all of all cancer patients
and the majority of cancer patients have
these cold tumors again cold tumors
meaning they're not immune infiltrated
at baseline they have less mutations
neoantigen generating mutations for your
immune system to target
and so even within though the patients
that we can treat which is the sort of
45 percent of patients with warmer hot
tumors
the actual objective response rates are
are not as high as we would like them to
be by far so really under 15
of those patients that we actually treat
if we consider sort of the warm tumor
patients as well as the hot tumor
patients uh actually have objective
clinical responses you know prs crs
so really there's there's a lot for us
to understand about why some patients
are responding and particularly these
cold tumor patients that make up the
majority of cancer patients uh we'd like
to find a way to reach them with
immunotherapy
and so even in in the hot tumor setting
melanoma where you know maybe we have a
60 response rate that still means 40 of
patients aren't responding and so roger
lowe's group looked into you know what
are the origins of that lack of response
in that 40 of patients and one of the
key gene sets they found enriched was
hypoxia so you know disordered
vasculature lack of oxygen supply
oxygen deprived
tissue led to
resistance to pd-1 blockade
immunotherapy
now we were interested because we're
interested in these cold tumors i
mentioned prostate pancreatic
across mouse models both transplantable
and spontaneous we found in the green
here
quite prevalent hypoxia and if we look
at you know published data from patients
we know that tumors like pancreatic
cancer and prostate cancer are among the
most hypoxic tumors uh in man
also it's you know for literally decades
we've known that
tumor hypoxia in the clinic inevitably
correlates with a worse outcome
and so what we found and and you know we
weren't the only ones i want to mention
others such as uh
um steve hatfield and misha zakowski's
group as well as greg del goff's group
we all observed this which is you know
this is our work in tram c2 prostate
cancer
under normoxia on the left
uh we see
you know there are t-cells the blue are
cd4s the better c8s this t cell response
is controlled by the presence of the
white fox p3 positive t cells but that's
a situation that we can reverse
uh with current sort of checkpoint
blockade antibodies we could expand
those effectors suppress those t-regs
turn that into
an effective tumor regressing response
the deeper problem though is in the
right panel where you see this large
area in green of hypoxia and there's
just no t salt there
no t cells there is a major problem for
pd1 antibodies ctla4 antibodies any kind
of checkpoint blockade because their
substrate is essentially t cells they
are resurrecting exhausted t cell
responses they are removing
engagement of these checkpoints on
t-cells so that they can't be shut off
but if there's none there to begin with
there's nothing for them to work with
and what you see on the the right side
is is again tsekowski's data showing the
same thing in a lung tumor the green is
hypoxia the red cells are t cells
there are t cells there but they're not
in these hypoxic zones
so
um
so the problem then is
why
why are we not seeing uh t-cells under
hypoxia and the truth is um
you know while we think about these
checkpoint barriers what we also need to
consider the metabolic barriers the
tumor is is a very harsh
metabolic landscape for t cells for a
number of reasons hypoxia which i
mentioned so lack of oxygen t cells
don't function well there but hypoxia
you know fosters development of
suppressive myeloid cells as well as
suppressive immune suppressive
polarization of cancer-associated
fibroblasts so t-cells are suffering
their sort of arch enemies are
flourishing
also nutrient deprivation so a lot of
these mdsc that are that are generated
um other myeloid cells uh such as tumor
associated macrophages they'll deplete
arginase they'll deplete tryptophan they
release toxic metabolites uh they
deplete glucose and glutamine and other
things that that
t-cells need for sort of essential
energy metabolism as do tumor cells uh
so you know they're starved of the
things they need
on multiple fronts to actually carry out
sort of successful metabolic expansion
and anti-tumor effector function
t cells hate acid ph and of course
within tumors we have lactic acid
deposition as a byproduct of warburg
effect as well as driven by hypoxia
carbonic anhydrase 9 upregulation and
carbonic acid
deposition you can find
you know phs in the tumor
microenvironment well below 6.5 at which
point you know t cells basically just
die
adenosine release another toxic uh
metabolite well not really toxic but
suppressive metabolite for t cells
released from tumor cells as well as
from uh
from other cells in the micro
environment that up regulate cd cd39 and
cd73 extracellular atp aces that
generate extracellular
adenosine from atp
and so why are we interested in um in
this from an immunoregulatory standpoint
well you know if you're a t cell
this doesn't look good i mean you know
there's so many levels of inhibition
that you're going to face in this micro
environment
and if we actually look you know why are
we interested in hypoxia specifically
many of these are actually in some ways
downstream of hypoxia so nutrient
deprivation is worsened by hypoxia
nucleating production of more m2
macrophages more mdsc that are producing
the arginase and the ido
they're increasing
tumor
metabolism
so therefore thereby you know tumor
metabolic adaptation to hypoxia leads
them to deplete more glucose glutamine
etc
acidification is worse you have more
lactate deposition as well as carbonic
anhydrase
9 being upregulated as a direct target
of hypoxia inducible factors and then
you know adenosine release is also
triggered by hypoxia cd39 and cd73 are
also
hif targets directly and so
all of this metabolic hostility ties
back to hypoxia so we wondered if we can
find a way to antagonize hypoxia maybe
we can relieve some of this sort of
suffocating pressure on t cell responses
that occurs in these tumors both
directly
and indirectly you know at the level of
vascular conditioning i mentioned sort
of nucleation of suppressive myeloid
cells really many levels of suppression
such that t cells basically become
non-functional and the environment
becomes not survivable for an active t
cell
so
that led to a bigger question how do you
go about reducing hypoxia in a solid
tumor
now if it's lung cancer you can hyper
oxygenate the lungs but for any other
solid tumor site you're limited by the
ability of
human blood to carry oxygen and
obviously disrupted vasculature causes
hypoxia so
you know how do you address that uh
problem well we were fortunate in that
somewhat serendipitously uh we
recognized that there was a drug that
was designed to be a hypoxia activated
pro prodrug so
much like a chemotherapeutic drug that
would only be activated under hypoxia
th3o2 that you know in the early data we
realized there were signs that 302 was
actually not working exactly as intended
but was having a really beneficial
effect in reducing tumor hypoxia
and you can see that in the upper left
panel here so these are sections through
whole [ __ ] c2 prostate tumors the green
is hypoxia you notice there's very
prevalent hypoxia
in [ __ ] in the untreated tumors
checkpoint blockade doesn't really
alleviate hypoxia but the drug alone or
in combination with immunotherapy is a
remarkable reducer of tumor hypoxia you
know with 40 40 or so of the tumors
being hypoxic at baseline you know 5
after drug treatment so really profound
in pancreatic cancer in the lower panel
which is really one of the most deeply
hypoxic of tumors due to both abnormal
angiogenesis and vascular stiffness
and contraction due to the desmoplasia
we also see very effective reduction of
hypoxia over time now this drug doesn't
reduce hypoxia immediately
mechanistically the way that 302 reduces
hypoxia is
it kills the selection of cells in this
micro environment thereby
initiating a tissue remodeling process
that rebuilds the faulty disorder
vasculature into new healthy vessels
really driven by
sort of replacement of the abnormal
angiogenesis driving
you know granulocytes uh
cancer-associated fibroblasts and tumor
cells with more of an m0 tissue
macrophage dominated population and you
can see that on the right where we see
an increase in cd31 positive vessel
density
with th3o2 treatment
so great so we can use this drug and
reduce hypoxia does it actually improve
tumor immunity and what we see in the
[ __ ] c2 transplantable models these are
tumors growing on the flank these tumors
actually are pretty sensitive to
checkpoint blockade at baseline
you see in the red that about 50 of
these uh mice can be cured uh with the
combination of ctla4 and pd1 blockade
remarkably we found that th3o2 alone
could actually trigger
an immune-based reaction that would cure
about 30 of these animals uh by itself
and and that actually
you know is fostered by breaking down
hypoxia and restoring t-cell
infiltration leading to actually
spontaneous regression again of about a
third of these tumors we know that's
immune dependent because we repeated
that experiment in rag knockout mice i
didn't put the data here that have no
adaptive immune system and the drug has
no effect at all as a monotherapy
now what we do see here that's
encouraging though both in the left
panel and in the right panel is that
when we use th 302 with checkpoint
blockade they're very very supportive of
one another so you know on the left
about 85 percent of these animals are
cured on the right about 95 but
basically
almost every animal can be cured of
these tumors by the combination of
immune checkpoint blockade and hypoxia
reduction the point of the right panel
is to show that the the
closest chemotherapy drug to th 302 that
is not hypoxia targeted which is
iphostomide doesn't have any of these
properties right this is a sort of
unique emergent property of very
selective uh remodeling of certain cell
populations only under the hypoxic
regions of tumors
so if we look a little deeper and we
look into these prostate tumors and ask
what's going on
both in the normoxic zones versus the
hypoxic zones of the same tumors again
in the untreated state and this time
again hypoxia is in green t cells are in
white vessels are in red
the myeloid components in blue what you
can see is that there are very few white
dots but a few in the normoxic zones of
untreated prostate tumors none under
hypoxia
when we use the drug alone you can see
this normalization of tumor vasculature
as well as where the yellow arrows are
you could actually see t cells now able
to extravazate off of these newer fuller
thicker vessels into these hypoxic areas
as they break down
now checkpoint blockade the combination
of ctla4 and pd1 is extremely effective
at inducing enhanced t-cell infiltration
on the normoxic areas but even with you
know nearly 100 t-cells per field in the
normoxic image you notice there there's
one or two and that's it breaking
through into these hypoxic zones
this um burden of suppression and you
know really sort of hostility
metabolically it means hypoxic areas is
almost impenetrable by sheer numbers so
numbers alone of t cells will not
overcome this
um
however what you see when we combine th
302 with checkpoint blockade we get a
tremendous infiltration of the normoxic
zones and now you also see very
high-level t-cell infiltration of these
hypoxic zones as they're breaking down
the t-cells can now survive there they
can now enter there vascular has been
norm vasculature has been normalized
oxygen's returning and you know that was
something we saw very reproducibly and
it's key to the therapeutic benefit of
this combination
now although t cells really dislike
hypoxic areas i mentioned on the other
hand suppressive myeloid stroma tumors
are are are nucleated there they they
love it they form there it favors
differentiation of m2 macrophages and
milo derived suppressor cells you know a
lot of this work was done by dimitri
gabrilovich um and what you can see here
is basically a reflection of that
you see that the overview of the gr1 the
overlay of the gr1 and
cd11b populations the white and the blue
is very dense in the untreated tumors
there are lots of myeloid derived
suppressor cells there are also lots of
m2 macrophages overlaying the red and um
and the blue
when we treat with the combination of
immunotherapy and hypothesis reduction
you see how depleted that gr1 positive
population is this this really
suppressive mdsc population thins out
tremendously and what takes over is
that remains
and what i'm not showing here is there's
a phenotypic switch of those not so much
from an m2 fully suppressive phenotype
to a immunostimulatory m1 but just back
to an m0 tissue macrophage no cd 163 no
cd 206 no arginase production
and really good at laying down new
healthy vessels at m0 macrophage would
be something you'd think of naturally as
being involved in wound repair
now if we look across the whole tumor
the impact of this on the mdsc
population's um pretty striking
across the whole tumor the frequency of
of arginase positive so the really you
know
verifiably suppressive mdsc drops by
about 50
um and you know if we look at it a
different way in terms of density we
also see about a
very substantial maybe 50 reduction so
really what we're seeing is that you
know the the establishment of this
highly suppressive myeloid barrier
throughout the tumor is pretty dependent
on the presence of these hypoxic areas
to uh to act as centers for suppressive
differentiation of these cells
so not only are these cells
less prevalent we also wanted to look at
them functionally and you know in the
untreated tumors you know maybe a fifth
of these these granulocytic mdsc or pmn
type mdsc are expanding so they're ki-67
positive
we actually see a reduction in that
proliferation uh with hypoxia reduction
and
immunotherapy you know now maybe only
five or ten percent of them are actually
proliferating so their their numbers
have been dramatically reduced and the
ones that remain are are considerably
less proliferative and able to respawn
re-expand and fill that gap
more importantly when we take these
cells out of the mouth and ask you know
how well do they suppress t cells given
there are very few still remaining
what we find is that if we look at a
situation where we've cfse labeled t
cells so they're you know they're
fluorescently positive as they
proliferate they dilute cfse so lower
signal means more proliferation with no
mdsc we see that the t cells have
proliferated diluted cfse
untreated you see that you know they
haven't proliferated we see
an intermediate signal with the
combination of checkpoint blockade and
hypoxia reduction again showing that
even though these mdscs are still to
some degree capable of repressing t-cell
responses they've actually lost a
substantial portion of their
functionality in that regard so there's
less of them they're less proliferative
and they're less
t-cell suppressive that's actually kind
of a major blow to
the immune privilege that tumors rely on
to exclude tumor immunity
now in some other experiments i'll tell
you about we saw hints that that you
know this response was actually more
durable after we pulled the drug away
than you would expect particularly um
not so much in the transplantable trap
model but in the [ __ ] transgenic mice
where you know we we wouldn't treat them
for three months and then we'd actually
still see that the prior treated ones
you know had a benefit in their micro
environment so we wanted to ask whether
you know when you take away hypoxia from
these tumors particularly when you do it
in the context of inducing new immune
infiltration
do you really durably compromise the
ability of the tumor to maintain this
immune privilege state
so the way that we did that we
established pretty large tram c2 tumors
so we left them established for over a
month before we started treating them we
only treated them with one cycle of
th3o2 with or without ctla4mp1 antibody
waited a couple days and then we
transferred into those mice congenitally
marked bone marrow progenitors asking
the question have we compromised the
ability of these tumors to then
attract these new congenitally marked
bone marrow progenitors and turn them
into new mdsc
and so we we waited a couple days
checked again
and what you see in panel a is that
uh the combination treated animals those
that received hypoxia reduction in
checkpoint blockade
had a dramatically reduced frequency of
granulocytic mdscs so things that looked
phenotypically like granulocytic mdsc
drawn from these new progenitors were
significantly reduced relative to the
other groups um
but when i say things that looked
phenotypically like gradual synthetic
mdsc the interesting thing is when we
looked functionally so in panel b
you see that unlike you know sort of a
card carrying mdsc uh the ones
forming in the mice that had had their
this hypoxic region reduced
they didn't really uh
they didn't really successfully
upregulate arginase a critical enzyme
involved in t cell suppression so really
one of the main drivers of mdsc
immediate diesel suppression
and they didn't down regulate fully mhc2
so you know as as you're moving let's
say my in the myeloid spectrum from m1
to m2 the critical shift is you're up
regulating suppressive functions like
arginase you're making more tgf beta
you're making more
pd ligands and you're down regulating uh
immunostimulatory functions less cd86
less mhc2
so you see that although phenotypically
you know in terms of markers these might
look like mdscs functionally they
haven't made it all the way there so
this really did tell us that hypoxia
reduction compromises functionally these
cells quite profoundly
all right so
all of this was really interesting but
everything i just showed you is in a
transplantable model of prostate cancer
that i mentioned at the beginning is
pretty sensitive at the baseline to
immune checkpoint blockade it does
respond to the combination of ctla4 and
pd1 blockade pretty well
responds a lot better when we also
diminish hypoxia but
you know the whole driver for doing this
research is that patients
with prostate cancer particularly
castrate resistant prostate cancer don't
respond to checkpoint blockade and so we
wanted to look at a model that similarly
was non-responsive to checkpoint
blockade and so [ __ ] mice so these are
these are spontaneous tumor developing
mice they have they start expressing
large t antigen and their prostate by
about 16 weeks of age that means they
spontaneously develop carcinoma in situ
as well as local metastatic disease
that progresses until you know by about
36 weeks of age they're starting to die
so we waited till that pretty late time
point of 16 weeks to start treating them
we treated them for about a month with
uh either th3o2 alone or the combination
with checkpoint blockade and then we
followed them for about you know three
more months with no more treatment at 36
weeks of age we euthanized them and we
looked at the weight of their prostates
now one other caveat about [ __ ] mice
that's worth mentioning
they get about 80
adenocarcinomas and about 20
neuroendocrine prostate tumors so that
is one thing to be aware of is it's
reflected in the data so what you can
see in the first panel on the right
ctla4pd1 blockade doesn't help these
animals right it's they have as much
tumor burden their prostates are as
heavy as untreated animals now th3o2
alone you have a slight reduction in the
size of the adenocarcinomas
which are the circles
no benefit to the triangles which is the
neuroendocrine tumors and
very little benefit overall although
some
what we really see that's striking
though is if we combine checkpoint
blockade that alone is completely
ineffective with th 302 that has the
best of marginal benefit
we get a dramatic reduction in prostate
weight with you know remarkably about a
third of these mice having the same sort
of weight of prostate as an age-matched
normal control mouse despite being
genetically programmed to develop these
cancers you know constantly throughout
their life so we're we're initiating an
immune response that is constantly
active and controlling emergence and
expansion of new cancer in these mice
the other thing that was really striking
and actually if you're wondering the
difference the panel on the right
shows you know both the neuroendocrine
and the endocarcinomas the
sorry panel on the left the panel on the
right shows just the adenocarcinomas um
so the other figure that i just popped
up here on the far right of the slide
though
shows again this frequency that i talked
about it's about an 80 20 split of
adenocarcinoma versus 20 neuroendocrine
carcinoma in these mice and that's what
we saw in the untreated the 302 alone
the antibody alone groups but remarkably
you'll see in the combination group you
know if you look at that first panel
there are no triangles if you look at
this bar you'll see that we have zero
uh neuroendocrine tumors
that either means you know quite
statistically so since we should have
had five or six um
that means that either they're being you
know immunologically eliminated or they
aren't developing in the context of
this combination therapy either way this
is a pretty interesting finding that
we're still hoping to explore
clinically
now not everybody loves the the [ __ ]
model because of the the way that it's
generated because it has this mix of
adenocarcinoma
and um
and neuroendocrine disease
so we also looked at what is an
immunologically extraordinarily
challenging model which is um
ron depino's
pb cree p10 smad
purely prostate adenocarcinoma model
because of the strength of these driver
mutations there are very very few
secondary mutations for the immune
system to target
in these mice so immunologically really
nothing has substantial traction here
in our case actually with the
combination we did see a pretty
significant extension of survival
so you know even in this setting which
is immunologically very challenging
we saw a pretty significant benefit to
this combination therapy
so all of that was telling us you know
is really working we're getting t cells
in the tumor we're seeing these tumors
uh regress spontaneous tumors
transplantable tumors you know something
good is going on here so we wanted to
understand mechanistically how that was
working
um
now if we were talking about melanoma
you know we always talked about cd8 to
t-reg ratios the suppressive foxb3
positive t-regs are are you know
keeping your active cd8 and cd4 effector
cells from expanding and regressing the
tumor
you do see an improvement in these
ratios of cd8 to t-reg ratio uh cdh and
t-regs with ctla-4p1 blockade with or
without gh3o2 but they're pretty modest
changes you know you go from about a one
to one ratio to maybe a three to one
ratio so if this were melanoma that
might be 20 to one or you know at least
10 to one the reason the cd8 to t-reg
ratios aren't as deterministic here as
the is that the real suppressive factor
holding down these t-cell responses
is the suppressive myeloid stroma in
these cold tumors and what you can see
at baseline you have this horrible
situation immunologically where there
are essentially five
arginase positive mdsc for every single
cd8 t cell that's not a very good
position to be in for the adaptive
immune response
ctla4 pd1 combination checkpoint
blockade increases the t cells a little
but they're still at a tremendous
disadvantage
um 302 alone we know will decrease the
the mdsc density but there's still
nothing helping the t cells to expand so
you put them together and you get this
really synergistic benefit where instead
of having 5 mdsc for every t cell you
have five cd8t cells for every mdsc this
is a much better situation
immunologically and we feel that this is
really the critical sort of cellular
uh switch
explaining the efficacy of this therapy
um if you know we're really removing
this heavy suppressive burden on t cells
we should see them you know look happier
in this micro environment and that is
what we see we see that their
proliferation of both the cd4 t-cell
effector population as well as the cd8
effectors uh increases in terms of ki-67
we see that the cytolytic capacity of
the cd8s increases both
in terms of
grand ibn on a personal basis measured
by mfi as well as in the percentage of
the population that's um grand time b
positive so cells are proliferating more
they have higher cytolytic capacity
if you know there are ways uh you can
look into the tumor microenvironment and
focus in on the subpopulation of cd8s
that's tumor specific as opposed to
bystanders et cetera
some people use cd39 as a marker for
this others um based on you know
rosenberg's findings from the nci use a
high 41 db expressing cd8 is a marker of
the antigen specific population we chose
that approach uh when you look at these
four and bb high
pressures from the till
you find that you know with hypoxia
reduction checkpoint blockade they're
more active in terms of cd44 they make
more interferon gamma when we stimulate
it they make
substantially more tnf when we're
stimulated so again this is telling you
not only do we have more t cells not
only do they have greater catalytic
potential
they're more activated and they have
greater cytokine effect or function
even in those spontaneous [ __ ]
mice which again we treat you know from
the time they're 16 weeks old to about
20 weeks old and then you know we pretty
much parked them for for three or four
months until they're 36 weeks old
without any further treatment
we were still able um at the end point
to observe better cda to tear egg ratios
better substantially c4 effector
deteriorate ratios and although it
wasn't statistically significant we saw
trends of greater
cd8 to granulocytic
mdsc ratios and this is again with these
mice not receiving treatment for three
or four months so so this gave us a
pretty good idea that this response much
like in the congenitally marked uh
myelin progenitor transfer was pretty
durable
um
so
you know there was a tom gaievsky paper
that you know some people would feel
that this is an obvious thing to look at
but someone had to prove it
and really what he showed was that
really sometimes whether your your
anti-tumor t-cell response succeeds or
fails is is really dependent on how well
those cells survive when they get to the
tumor if they just get to the tumor and
they die at a high frequency
the tumor is going to win and it's going
to progress if they can maintain
effector function and survive long
enough to actually you know get a leg up
in the numbers game against the tumor
cell then you have successful anti-tumor
immunity
well in light of that i thought this
finding was particularly interesting so
if we look at the t cells infiltrating
these [ __ ] c2 tumors
and we look in the normoxic region
versus the hypoxic region we see very
little cell death so very little caspase
positive t cells in the normoxic areas
but if we turn over to the hypoxic
areas you know we see tremendously high
caspase expression in the untreated
tumors where basically almost almost all
the t cells we can find there are at
some stage of apoptotic death
whereas when we reduce hypoxia with
combination therapy we see that sort of
you know ongoing death process
under hypoxia diminished by about half
in those t cells so i think this gets to
this longevity standpoint now we have t
cells that can survive sort of
indefinitely in normoxia we've expanded
significantly the percentage of the
tumor that is normoxic and even in these
remaining hypoxic pockets um the t cells
can survive a lot better than they could
before
all right so all of that data together
you know really told us that
the drug that we found 302 can really
reduce hypoxia and then our hypothesis
that reduction of hypoxia would allow
greater infiltration of active t cells
and then maybe sensitize some of these
cold tumors to checkpoint blockade um
you know had really seemed to hold up
and particularly in some of these really
therapeutically intransigent
spontaneous tumor models of prostate
cancer
we also you know some work that i'm not
going to show we also validated the same
kind of pattern and finding in um in
head and neck cancer
and actually greg delgaf's group has
published some work more recently in
head and neck cancer as well so with all
of this data out there you know for us
this was enough to say okay we should
find out if this works in patients so
david hong led this clinical trial he's
been a fantastic collaborator of mine
he's deputy chair of our uh phase one
group our investigational cancer
therapeutics department
um and and so what we were looking at
was
in um
cold tumor patients those with
pancreatic cancer
hormone refractory prostate cancer as
well as hpv negative head and neck
um
if we treat them just with 302
or its other name is evil phosphamide
with epilimumab ctla4 blockade you know
can we rescue some of these patients
that have failed you know many many
lines of prior therapies
and what you can see is we actually had
a what we felt was a really encouraging
result in this early phase trial it was
a dose escalation of equal phosphate at
the 400 dose the lowest dose i think we
were sub therapeutic but if you look at
where we got to
with the higher doses you'll see that
overall across these patients we had
about an 18 objective response rate and
and over 80 disease control rates so
meaning stable disease partial responses
complete responses and some of these
responses were quite profound in very
refractory patients
on the right as well where you see the
spider plots what you can see is um you
know not only are some of these you know
deeper responses more meaningful but the
stable disease is pretty meaningful in
this very advanced cancer uh patient
population so you see those two lines
that run across the middle kind of
yellow colored those are pancreatic
cancer patients they had failed you know
they're metastatic they had failed all
standard of care they had failed
generating failed full fear knocks and
were on this trial for over a year
without progression that alone is a
remarkable finding even beyond the
actual recess level responses
one other thing you'll notice in this
graph is the green arrows so
you know we were very conservative about
the way that we designed this trial up
front because we didn't know if you know
having the drug concurrent with
immunotherapy might negatively affect
the t cell response so we only gave the
drug
evil phosphate in the first two cycles
along with
epilimimab and implement
standard fda approved three mig per kg
four doses uh regimen
what we found though is that patients
were coming back to us you know four
five six months later saying hey
you know my
ca 199 is going back up my psa is going
back up it looks like my cancer is
coming back
maybe you could give me some more of
that stuff you gave me a few months back
that actually you know got me to where i
am now
it's a really good argument and so we
went back to our irb and put in an
amendment so that we could retreat those
patients now these things take time and
you know by the time we actually got
approval to do this we were only able to
capture maybe you know six or seven
additional patients that we were able to
retreat
what you see is almost every patient we
retreated responded so
we had a prostate patient that was
having a very strong response that
lowest red line he became nearly a
radiographic cr we had a head and neck
patient that was relapsing we treated
her she stayed on the trial for a couple
additional months both the pancreatic
patients that were on over a year were
retreated in fact the only patient that
didn't really have you know an extremely
durable response to retreatment was
another prostate patient
and unfortunately he had had a grade
three adverse event to uh epilimumab in
his last cycle up front so our irb would
only allow us to retreat him with evo
still he managed to stay on the trial
for for a couple additional months as
well so
the good news about when you retreat
patients and they all respond is that it
really tells you you know this is being
driven by this therapy th3o2 plus uh
epilimumab it's not some you know we had
a couple patients have some miraculous
late response to some other therapy they
had
that's good because it tells us that our
therapy is driving this the bad news is
it probably means we under-treated
everybody to some extent if everybody
you retreat responds and we're gonna
address that in the phase two
when i say some of these responses were
really profound you know and some of
these patients were heavily
pre-treated i just wanted to give one
example so
you know this was a metastatic prostate
patient
you know presented with an extremely
large involvement of the liver
multiple bone mats
um you know he was hormone refractory he
failed you know standard taxing salvage
chemotherapy he'd failed a very creative
attempt to salvage him with a gem soda
beans his platens platinum chemical
chemotherapy combination that is
certainly not standard for prostate
cancer as well as you know radiotherapy
all kinds of things so
really you know this gentleman had
exhausted any available therapies that
were out there
uh within you know our first um
measurement point at about eight weeks
uh he already had very substantial
reduction of the liver tumor you see
that here
and once we retreated him uh his overall
uh rhesus tumor measurement dropped you
know almost 10 to minus 90 actually
later uh and and you know he's still
responding so this was a very durable
very profound response you know with
some of his bone disease disappeared
etcetera this was
a systemic durable uh response against
this cancer so you know this was really
encouraging you know these were really
pretty heavily pre-treated patients and
so
we wanted to get to was it you know
fortunately we were able to obtain both
blood and biopsies from these patients
and we wanted to see you know are we
seeing patterns reminiscent of what we
saw in our pre-clinical studies and what
other things do we need to take back to
the lab to try to investigate further so
we can do a little better you know the
next round
now one thing we saw when we looked at
the blood of these patients was that you
know
a lot of the time it's very difficult to
look at pbmc or peripheral blood
mononuclear cells because the signal to
noise
is often not very good and the noise
sometimes drowns out your signal but in
this case we saw a very clear signal
that the patients that went on to
respond to therapy
showed an increase in their peripheral
cd8 and cd4 t cell populations that that
were expanding so ki 67 positive uh cd8s
and cd4s in the periphery uh
expanded you know significantly um it
was actually really
nice to see statistically significant
improvements in such a small trial
also on the other side we saw that
patients who came in up front so now
we're talking about a pre-treatment
marker response or non-response in this
case
patients that came in up front with a
high level of circulating
granulocytic mdsc and or monocytic mdsc
uh had less of a likelihood of
responding now this was not
statistically significant but it was a
pretty strong trend in the in the
non-responders that they had a higher
circulating uh arginase expression uh in
their mdsc so
high arginase pmn mdsc high arginase
monocytic mdsc
uh did not bode well for subsequent
response
now i mentioned we got biopsies so we
were really interested to see what was
going on within the tumor and obviously
we have we had blood from all our
patients
you know we only had a limited number of
paired biopsies so three non-responding
patients and six responding patients
even in this frequency of patients you
can see that there was a really strong
trend toward increased proliferation in
the cda t cells in the tumor so much
like what we saw in the pre-clinical
setting
increased cd4 t cell proliferation
and also so with pimonidazole so these
patients take piminidazole which is the
same marker that was marking the hypoxia
and all the images i showed you
um and with flow cytometry we could say
you know
how well were the hypoxic areas
infiltrated by t cells by dendritic
cells etc
so again even with the small number of
patients we saw a very statistically
significant increase in cd4 t cells able
to infiltrate
formerly hypoxic areas from which they
were probably excluded before
cd8 t cells similar trend more
infiltration more hypoxia exposure
they're able to infiltrate and survive
in these hypoxic areas same with
dendritic cells where you know dendritic
cells are really important for
initiating tumor immunity also uh very
very uh excluded from hypoxic areas
normally
finally you know we wanted to to look at
sort of the genetics and say you know
are we really seeing a clear signature
of response versus non-response which is
something else that gives you
further confidence that it's your
therapy that's driving these responses i
didn't mark out the individual genes
here but what you can see is you know
between the progressors and the partial
responding patients there's quite a
distinct gene signature that holds up
even when we compare the partial
responding patients to the patients with
very short-term stabilization of disease
less than two months
and even comparing the short-term stable
disease to the long-term stable to these
patients we see a very significant
difference in gene expression so this
told us we had a very
concrete biomarker signature associated
with response versus resistance
now finally on the right you know
there are real limitations to how much
you can ask is hypoxia being reduced
because we're taking biopsies right and
did those biopsies come from the same
place you know et cetera et cetera there
are lots of caveats
still we were really interested to see
that you know if we looked in the
non-responders on treatment versus
pre-treatment we saw greater
uh
by by transcription factor analysis we
saw greater upregulation of a hif or
hypoxia induced factor
if one driven transcriptional signature
so hypoxia seem to be getting worse
whereas in the responders between
pre-treatment and
on-treatment we actually saw reduced
hif1 transcription factor analysis
signal so
transcriptional patterns associated with
hif we're going down in the responding
patients up in their in the
non-responding patients this says you
know it's certainly a consistent finding
with the mechanism of action of this
therapy that we hypothesize
so if we saw this this sort of very
concrete gene separation or genetic
separation of responders versus
non-responders you know what did we
learn from that
well if we look at
gene said enrichment analysis a hallmark
analysis from gene said analysis what we
can see is that the number one gene set
associated with non-response or
progression was high oxfos and and also
we see higher fatty acid metabolism
higher glycolysis
this is what we call a hyper metabolic
phenotype and i'll mention that we've
observed this before in some settings
so what this represents is
these tumors are so efficiently
ratcheting up their metabolism that
they're essentially starving t cells out
for essential
energetic nutrients in the
microenvironment and also bathing them
in some you know rather
difficult metabolites for t cells to
cope with you know lactate reactive
oxygen species etc
in that context hypoxia reduction alone
may be insufficient to metabolically
restore t-cell function
on the other hand in the responders we
saw evidence of underlying particularly
innate inflammatory responses interferon
alpha inflammatory response genes et
cetera stat5 signaling
as well as some early signs of adaptive
immunity in terms of interfering gamma
but not the kind of adaptive immune
signature that's been associated with
for instance response to ctla4 a
response to pd1
this is quite distinct and i think what
this represents is
when you have some underlying innate
inflammation but the presence of hypoxia
is preventing
that from actually nucleating a real
adaptive immune response that could be
mobilized against the tumor
the drug reducing that hypoxia now
allows this underlying inflammation to
manifest into better adaptive immune
filtration and anti-tumor immunity
so we do have a phase two trial planned
um
approximately 50
pancreatic prostate and hpv negative
head and neck patients
this is kind of an exciting trial for us
in addition to ctla 4 blockade much like
you saw the preclinical data these
patients will also receive pd1 blockade
again we feel like we probably under
treated them a little in the first trial
so they'll be getting
they'll be getting evophosphamide for
the first three cycles of their
immunotherapy as well so a little more
chance for as you know for us to sort of
plateau the amount of hypoxia reduction
and we'll be doing some hypoxia imaging
of these patients using the 18f fosa pet
tracer so for us this is a really
exciting one uh we're hoping it'll open
around the november or december of this
year
now where else have we seen this you
know high oxford signature associated
with checkpoint blockade resistance and
i'll say again you know greg delgoff has
published on this phenomenon as well so
um
we were lucky enough to be involved with
another trial uh you know sort of
stemming from some some work we had done
or very similar to some work we had done
pre-clinically looking at hpv
vaccination and checkpoint blockade
where bonnie glsen led a trial at md
anderson looking at um
pd1 blockade with the volume ab combined
with the iso 101 hpv vaccine
and and what we saw if you see on the
right panel was you know as opposed to
the baseline let's say you know 10 to 20
percent more like 13
response rate to pd-1 blockade in these
patients
uh the response rate in this trial was
more like 36 so really you about tripled
the response compared to pd1 alone
we'll go into that you know vaccination
gives us a higher again substrate of t
cells for that pd-1 blockade to work
with
they work together very well hpv e6 and
e7 are ideal antigens because they're
virally derived essential for
maintenance of the transformed phenotype
the tumor can't just stop expressing
them
and so we're really happy to see this
result
but even in this trial when we looked at
what are the gene sets associated with
lack of response to this you know really
therapeutically potent combination of
pd-1 blockade and
tumor antigen vaccination
oxfoss again number one gene set and so
we were seeing this over and over
so we went back to the lab and we looked
at some other data we had from a mouse
model and that data showed us that
um you know there are two origins of
hypoxia right in tumors so one that
we've talked about and the one that we
addressed with th 302
disordered vasculature leads to lack of
oxygen supply
which you know leads to hypoxia but the
other side of the equation is hyper
oxygen consumption so elevated oxford
metabolism
by tumors also promotes hypoxia by you
know basically eating all of the oxygen
that's available in the microenvironment
acting together these two mechanisms
establish a truly
um
deep hypoxia that t cells you know have
again a huge struggle to survive and
function within
and so you know we had done a prior uh
experiment where we took a
melanoma tumor so b16 melanoma and mice
treated them with both ctla4 pd1 and
pdl1 blockade in the context of a
vaccine the data i showed you in the
very first slide i showed you
which is about 70 or 80 curative
we took the 20 that didn't get cured put
them back into new mice treated them
again and we kept repeating that until
we evolved the tumor line that was
completely refractory to the original
immunotherapy that cured 80 of them and
then we asked well how did that
you know how did these b16 melanomas
that were so sensitive to triple
checkpoint blockade become completely
resistant
and i'll be honest with you we expected
to find they had upregulated new novel
checkpoints or they were making a ton of
immunosuppressive cytokine but the truth
is the main changes were all metabolic
and what you could see is that when we
looked on the right panel
at this immune resistant melanoma we
found that it had highly upregulated
oxfos
there was enhanced uh adaptation to
hypoxia so this gene set
um labeled as hypoxia it's actually a
gene set associated with adaptation of
hypoxic stress
as well as adaptation to oxidative
stress so when you up regulate oxfos
metabolism you're going to be creating
as a byproduct a lot more reactive
oxygen species um it's the up regulation
the coincident upregulation of the
oxidative stress machinery that allows
tumors to actually you know sort of
prosper in the face of this high ross
level
on the other hand if instead we looked
in the micro environment so this was a
model where we could separate the tumor
cells from the surrounding stroma
in the surrounding stroma you know as
the tumors sort of flourished and
increased their ox fats and oxygen
consumption the stroma was deprived of
oxford's metabolism basically the tumor
is hyper consuming all the oxygen
there's nothing left for the stroma
um hypoxic adaptation
or or adaptation of toxic stress was
exactly inverted from the tumor so so
these stroma were experiencing um high
signatures of being exposed to high
levels of oxidative stress so think of
it as a
lack of adaptation to hypoxic stress and
of course cd8 cell effector function
associated genes bottomed out right so
you're you're the immune component of
this stroma that can no longer prosecute
oxford's metabolism and is now being
exposed to intense hypoxic and oxidative
stress
is non-functional
and so we thought of this you know
mechanistic study in light of finding
this
hypox gene set associated with you know
lack of response in our hypoxia
immunotherapy trial lack of response in
our
pd-1 vaccine trial
and so we went back to the lab and said
well can we also inhibit oxfos what
happens if we block that end of the
equation at the same time we're trying
to remodel vasculature and restore
oxygenation with h3o2
now i will say that you know there
there's
there's some amount of lack of
selectivity of oxfast inhibitors and t
cells do need some amount of loss
metabolism particularly when they're
activating and expanding initially
however what we saw with one particular
oxfast inhibitor shown here which is the
ix-10759 inhibitor was that in the
context of checkpoint blockades so ctla4
and pd1 blockade we had a much higher
density of t cells in red here uh
when we combined ctla4 and pd1 with
1.759 and what you can see sort of in
the bar graph is that t cells alone is
under the vehicle plus anti-ctla for
anti-pd1 um there's pretty much nothing
there at day 12 where there's this huge
bar it's a very significant both cd3
under normoxia and cv300 hypoxia with a
combination with oxford inhibitor so
that was telling us t-cell density in
the tram c2 tumors was improved in the
context of immunotherapy and oxford
inhibition
so that led us to investigate a little
further you know how far we could push
this pathway and we looked at three
oxfast inhibitors so these are three
that are sort of clinically relevant uh
iax10759 which i showed you im156 from
immunomet and metformin which metformin
can inhibit oxfords at high
concentrations it's a little bit of a
dirty drug because as you all know it
also does many other things however this
is where we focused our efforts
and that was just seahorse assays
showing you that they they all really do
suppress oxford's metabolism
what we found we looked at 10759 or 156
was that when we use them in combination
with th 302 which is the pink line in
the graphs on on the left
you know they they had a very
significant additive benefit maybe even
synergistic in in suppressing tram c2
tumor growth so even without putting
immunotherapy on top
just combining th 302 and oxford's
inhibition um again which is for us
getting to both the sort of push pull of
this origins of hypoxia
had a very strong therapeutic benefit
now in the right panels you see we did
combinations with ctla4 and pd1 blockade
and here in the combination setting the
tumors were you know essentially wiped
out so we really saw you know some very
encouraging data
unfortunately you know the tumors were
really wiped out uh both by the
combinations of the oxfox inhibitor
alone and checkpoint blockade as well as
the triple combination with ctla4 pd1
and th3o2 so we have follow-on studies
uh in a harder to treat tumor model
where we're trying to to you know really
get a cleaner idea of how much additive
or synergistic benefit there is where
we're not really just curing everything
with all the combinations however we
found this really encouraging and it's
something we're trying to develop as a
way to address this resistance that
we're seeing in the clinic
um when we look mechanistically i won't
go into too much detail but you can see
that you know when we combine th 302 and
oxfos inhibitor 107.59
we see high-level cd8 ki-67
proliferation in the tumor high-level
grants ib production
cd4-t effector proliferation is high
a lot of this is driven by the ctla4 pd1
alone but we definitely see
some benefit in the triple
therapeutically
where where is that coming from well one
place we see it is in down regulation of
arginase production by tumor associated
macrophages
again i mentioned the benefit of hypoxia
to them in terms of uh you know m2
polarization and arginine subregulation
there's also a benefit of oxford's
metabolism
and and mhc2 upregulation is is really
high in the context of arginase down
regulation something we see associated
with really like an m1 phenotypic switch
so we're we're still developing this
data the last pieces aren't published
but um
but you know we're seeing a really
encouraging trend that if we can block
tumor oxfords uh or diminish it in the
context of restoring oxygenation with th
302
we create a much more favorable
metabolic environment for antitumor
immunity particularly driven by t cells
so that's it i want to thank in
particular the people in my lab that did
this work
um
priya is the postdoc who's really led
all of this she's fantastic um arthur
krithika and you know prior um megan and
meet on ashvin did some of that work i
told you about with the the resistant uh
melanoma line and
you know seeing oxfords and hypoxic
stress uh upregulation
so um again also thank david hong and
immunogenesis and molecular templates
for their work on the clinical trial and
you know thanks again to lab roots for
giving me this opportunity to present
and i hope you all enjoyed the talk